i fear pranks uh people think of me as a
humorous fellow
some of you some people do and they um
they always think oh you must love
pranks i hate pranks because i'm afraid
to pull a prank yeah i don't want to be
comfortable enough praying but you and
your friends apparently like to pull
pranks on you
don't set me up like that i'm not like
clooney like there's people that pull
pranks and then there's people like me
that have a lot of friends that pull
pranks
i mean my friends and i used to be
really bad kids before we were
um accountable by law we were really
like
we did a lot of really bad stuff but
like what what like a bat you did
bad stuff i mean we we like tried to
make sure that we really
towed that line between a restable
offense and just
mayhem because my problem with pranks is
a lot of times people will tell you
about a prank they put when they were
the kid you hear what you think no
that's just a crime
yeah i played this great fruits with
7-eleven with a gun and i got the money
april fools no it's a crime
no no no we you know we were just like
silly we we
there was a there was a point in time
where all over la there were giant
inflatables on the top of people's
buildings like advertising
like uh businesses and stuff like big
businesses like all this king kong or
this bat
person remember yeah giant balloon yeah
like huge no
all over the place yeah but it's a
really simple construct and
you know my friends and i can climb so
we would always get up on like whatever
roof it was we broke down the way the
mechanics of it worked and
it's an air blower that's plugged in and
then it's tethered down so we were like
oh we just untie all these tethers this
thing's going to like shoot straight up
in the air
and so we did that like all the way no
you can't that's again that's not a
prank
that's a crime well we don't these
things fly up into the air and then do
what they land in traffic
so well it was always like really late
at night you know it's not there
but there is planes can't see them very
well when you're
when you're like 16 years old and sort
of organizing your world view there's
something very satisfying about watching
a two-story king kong fly up like 30
feet in the air
and then sag in the middle of lankersham
boulevard
progressively sadder all right well
what's up what's an example of a prank
you're doing now like well not that i'm
doing now but there was
a great prank one of my friends went out
of town and she was like all right so i
left
my keys with this person and like take
care of my cats
and uh my oh no
so my wife and and a couple of our
friends were like all right guys let's
uh
stage the most brutal crime scene we can
in her apartment while she's gone and
they did they just
what do you mean i mean like everything
from bloody handprints to exterior
windows to
tape outlines of the cat with an
evidence marker
but the cat's safe of course i can't
save it well i can't trust with you you
were throwing
what do you mean of course the key
you've got king kong descending on
lancashire i don't know what you do to a
cat that's a balloon
so wait a minute so there's an out chalk
outline of the cat there's bloody
handprints there's
they didn't they wrote on rodent blood
on the mirror vanity you know
like um left left a baby ruth in the
toilet like it was
you know they put they put police tape
across the door
and the best thing was all the neighbors
called my friend on vacation they're
like there's police tape on your door
she goes it's probably a prank if there
was
really a police situation someone would
have actually called me besides my
neighbor
right and then uh the friend who was
supposed to be watching the place like
came to the house with my friend on the
phone and was like really afraid to open
the door
and the first thing that you see when
you walk in the door is the outline of
the cat right yeah and so she just
screams oh my god your cat is dead no
they're like way to overreact right but
right away
yeah it's her fault
but so my friend knew it was a joke
obviously because they don't they don't
make chalk outlines of animals
kitty cat csi yeah
uh i have to ask you something you uh
but kitty cat
csi just sounds like it should star all
cats like they'd walk in the obviously
[Laughter]
back and then one cat that just takes
its glasses off